Autism is a development disorder that
affects an individual's ability to socialize and communicate.
Asperger's syndrome is part of the autism spectrum
but it differs because usually individuals diagnosed with Asperger's
have normal to higher IQs.
overall though, both have many overlapping similarities,
and it is still being debated today
as to whether or not the two terms need to exist as separate diagnoses
Our mission is to break down stigmas,
myths, and misconceptions associated with autism.
Many of our viewers have expressed concerns about the
misunderstandings that surround this disorder,
so we want to provide support to them and raise awareness.
Here are five facts you need to know about autism.
One, symptoms and signs of autism.
Before we begin with this point,
we want you to know that it's never a good idea to self diagnose.
Please visit a health professional in order to receive reliable insights.
According to Autism Speaks, more than 2 million people have autism spectrum
disorder and one in 59 of those people are children.
Statistics also show that autism affects more boys than girls
The signs that health professionals look for in patients include:
social challenges, communication, difficulties and repetitive behavior.
Children with autism have trouble responding to social cues
such as returning a wave to someone
or being responsive when someone calls their name
They also have higher disinterest in people
starting at a young age
experienced a delay in learning speech
and have trouble reading body language.
For instance, if someone is mad and crosses their arms
or expresses in patience by tapping their foot
People with autism can't pick up on that right away
they also tend to follow strict rigid schedules
and struggle with change.
people with autism have few specific interests
that they are intensely devoted to
Two, causes of autism. Researchers have discovered that
there are many factors that influence the development of autism.
one of them involves a specific gene that causes it.
Other factors that are not genetic related involve environmental risks
and events that happened before or during pregnancy
for instance a baby may be susceptible to developing autism
if the mother breathed in high levels of air pollution
while she was pregnant
or when the baby experiences a lack of oxygen in their brain,
But none are certain and scientists are still searching
for a definitive cause ultimately.
However, most adults with autism are less concerned with finding a cause
than they are with being accepted
and better understood by society
Three, treatment options. Unlike many disorders,
there is no medication that can specifically treat autism.
Many people with autism use cognitive behavioral therapy
in order to regulate their emotions
and to work on their impulse control.
There are also support groups they can join,
speech therapists they can work with,
and training sessions they can attend
to build their social and motor skills
related symptoms people with autism
may experience such as anxiety depression and ADD
can also be treated with the proper dosage prescribed by a health professional.
For what teachers can do, educating children with autism
can be highly challenging.
But here are some helpful tips they can use
when creating lesson plans,
Learn about what your students with autism like.
People with autism have very distinct interests,
so if you can incorporate them to make
your lessons interesting,
This can help them engage with the material more.
Another way is to allow for group discussions,
classroom discussions may be intimidating for students with autism
but one-on-one interactions is more approachable for them.
It's also important to provide structure
and a schedule for them to follow.
Predictability is crucial.
Five, what parents can do.
It's important for parents to remember that
when their child has autism, they may have a hard time
fitting in in school,
or relating to other children.
Be mindful of their habits
and teach them to love themselves for who they are.
Provide a safe structure for them to thrive in
and attend programs where you can stay educated on autism
and enroll your child in classes
where they can work on their skills.
Recognize that it will be a challenging journey ahead
but with your love and support it can go a long way
towards the progress they make.
Do you struggle with autism or know someone who does?
Please share your thoughts with us below!
We also provided some helpful sources
you can check out in our description box.
Please be sure to subscribe to our channel as well
for more helpful tips and share this video with others.
With your help we can reach more people to spread awareness on
mental health issues.
Thanks for watching. ^_^